les réfugiés instalement qui sont
actuellement en Hongrie devraient
arriver en Allemagne de l'Ouest dès
demain un passage collectif qui sera le
plus important depuis la construction du
mur de Berlin en 1961 et c'est réfugiés
devraient être hébergés dans un premier
temps dans des villages de temps qui
peuvent accueillir un peu plus de 4000
personnes en Bavière jusqu'à la
frontière juste à côté de la frontière
avec l'Autriche fibre chaud sur place
le camp de Tiphaine bar à 10 km de la
frontière autrichienne peut accueillir
700 personnes il est le dernier des cinq
camps de toiles que la Croix Rouge
allemande a pu bâtir ce week-end c'est
que l'Allemagne fédéral veut accueillir
convenablement les cinq ou dix mille
réfugiés d'Allemagne de l'Est qui vont
arriver ici en Bavière après avoir
attendu un mois en gris avec l'espoir de
passer de l'autre côté d'un rideau de
fer devenu une véritable passoire
mobilisation générale dans le sud de
l'Allemagne la Bundes verts met aussi
ses casernes à leur disposition dans les
camps on leur installe le téléphone en
espérant que les communications avec
l'Allemagne de l'Est ne seront pas
coupées en représailles afin qu'au moins
les réfugiés puissent avertir leur
famille demeurer à l'Est qu'ils sont
bien arrivés il resteront trois jours
ici et subiront tous des interrogatoires
pour que l'on sache si parmi ces
milliers de réfugiés ne se cachent pas
des espions 50 wagons spéciaux ont été
affrétés par l'Allemagne fédérale pour
transporter dans de bonnes conditions
les réfugiés est allemand et pourtant
cette nuit encore une vingtaine on
franchi facilement la frontière
la vie n'était pas facile pour moi en
République démocratique allemande
j'avais besoin de découvrir le monde je
veux de la liberté c'est pour cela que
je suis parti
aux frontières de l'Autriche de la
Hongrie et de l'Allemagne fédérale tout
est prêt l'opération peut être
déclenchée d'un jour à l'autre elle se
fera en bonheur avec une seule question
combien seront-ils à franchir cette
frontière